Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show, I am Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in for David Pakman all of this week.
Let's talk about January six, shall we?
Obviously, in the last few weeks here, we've
gotten some very important news.
I would call it about the events of that day,
the events before that day, the PowerPoints,
the text messages, the emails, the phone calls,
all kinds of stuff.
But some of the most important information
we've gotten about January six has actually
come from the courts.
Late last week, the harshest sentence to date
for one of the Capitol rioters was handed
down the man who assaulted a police officer
with a fire extinguisher.
Sentenced to a little more than five years
in prison.
And of course, this individual expressed his.
Sorrow, his sadness at what he did, you know,
got the crocodile tears going.
But.
Judge didn't buy it.
Still sentence him to more than five years.
And this is becoming routine at this point.
This is what we're seeing happening.
With these judges in the sentences that they're
handing down.
And here's why.
And this is very important, and this is something
that everybody needs to understand about the
cases these judges are hearing.
Because judges are telling us this past week.
That January six is it's not over.
It's not over.
And the reason for that is because what radicalized
these individuals has not stopped, it has
not gone away.
While these particular people, the ones who
have been sentenced, the ones who are going
to jail are currently in jail, they're probably
not as likely to engage in that kind of behavior
in the future.
We're still creating another army, essentially
of these crazed people who think the election
was stolen.
That's what January six was.
Here's another thing I filled in for David
back in August, one of the stories I talked
about at the time, I remember vividly.
Was the fact that judges back in August.
We're telling us.
That we're probably facing another January
six type situation.
Because of the radicalization process, because
the Big Lie still persisted out there.
And in fact, because it was being pushed even
harder in August than it was in January.
And now here we are, four and a half months
after those judges told us that more judges
came out in the past week and effectively
told us the same thing.
That we can expect more, we can expect worse,
and we can expect this because the radicalization
still exists because nothing has been done
to stop it, because honestly, it's hard to
stop it right?
These people have free speech.
We can't tell them they're not allowed to
say these things.
That's illegal.
But they're also not being held accountable
by the media outlets who allow them to say
these things.
On their social media platforms, where they
spew these lies every day in the speeches
that they give, and again, part of this is
because there's literally nothing we can do
about it.
All we can do is go out there every day and
talk about how this is a lie.
This is not true.
All of the evidence, including the audits
and investigations conducted by conservative
groups, are all telling us there's no fraud.
There was no theft.
But even still, 70 percent of the Republican
Party believes Joe Biden is not the duly elected
president of the United States that the 2020
election was stolen.
70 percent of Republicans believe that now.
And if we had listened to these judges months
ago, that wouldn't come as a shock.
What happened on January 6th was kind of an
immediate radicalization of individuals who
were most of them, probably kind of already
on the edge.
They were hard core supporters.
They had their feelings hurt that their guy
didn't win or.
And then he told them, go fight like hell
or you won't have a country anymore.
How one of the accused rioters last week in
front of a judge said Trump gave me permission
to do this.
I had a right to storm the Capitol because
the former president gave me permission.
So they took that that one statement from
him, and while the rest of it as well, that
was their action and they went with it.
That's how quickly that radicalization happened
for many of those individuals, for the rest
of them, we're talking about radicalization
that's been going on for a year now.
Radicalization that is taking hold within
the Republican Party to the point seventy
percent look at Joe Biden and say that man
who I also think is incompetent somehow stole
the election.
For the record, two things can't be true there,
he can't be such an incompetent idiot, you
can't even stay awake and a mastermind who
stole the 2020 election.
That makes no sense.
Yet this is what they believe, and the judges
are still out there warning us that, yeah,
things are going to get bad again, things
are probably going to be worse than what they
already were.
Because nothing is being done, and in many
instances, there's nothing legal we can do
about it.
All we can do is fight back against the misinformation.
And as somebody who does do this every day,
and I'm sure David feels the same way, sometimes
it feels like this Sisyphean task.
We're pushing this boulder up the hill, only
to watch it roll back down again and start
all over.
There's no end, there's no there's no clear
victory here.
We're just destined to do this forever to
fight back against this conservative misinformation.
But like Sisyphus himself, we're never going
to stop.
As part of our job, it's what we do.
It's how we help.
So that's what we're doing here.
That's what these judges are trying to do,
they're giving us the warnings, and if we
don't heed these warnings, then yeah, we're
probably going to be looking at something
much worse than what happened on January 6th
at some point in the future.